helpful advice yes Oh is there another
question there's a question I'm a fan
I'm hopeful advice with Bobby
kalila and Steve Bird did you just do
that oh it's a modulator hold right here
don't say I would say right now this
Chicago second city not only that I
thought it was crazy
I told him to do open for me what he
never done standing before yeah I'm not
kidding you you rocked the house and
never done it before yeah this guy is a
natural yes he won't do it because he
was he wants to be on a TV show and an
audition go ahead dear Bobby kalila and
Steve my name is Cedric from France I'm
20 years old and I live in Belgium in
November 2018 my younger sister did a
suicide attempt
she survived and is doing well
physically but mentally is a different
story ever since it happened I quit my
job I feel no emotion unless I'm drunk I
have no energy for daily stuff and my
place is a mess and I slept for 12 hours
straight it just seems like I can't be
happy unless the people I love are my
question is how do I get my life back on
track and feel human again
Cedric greetings from Belgium the
heaviest one we've ever gotten I think
the great news is the acknowledgement
you know that I think that's a step I
would I would assume I'm not obviously
I'm not a professional but I I assume
that the outreach of help should be
something positive that said jury can
take saying I'm at least acknowledging
what's going on and I'm reaching out for
help and I think that that's a good sign
but I think maybe I also think you
should put the oxygen mask on yourself
first before trying to help other people
I meant that this is a general rule of
life also because we have the tendency
as humans when we love so deeply to give
so much of ourselves to them that we
only leave scraps for ourself and I
think that's probably what's happening
he's been so emotionally invested in his
sister's well-being that he's given just
scraps to himself so I think that he
needs to focus on him getting better
putting the blinders on and only then
he'll be able to finally get his sister
to maybe you know lead her in the right
there
action it it's not as bad but it kind of
reminds me of when I would I got sober
at that second time and my brother was
sobered there but when I relapse he had
to relapse and so when I got sober sober
the second time my brother was still
using right and he was out there for a
couple years she's partying you know and
I'd go to this house and it would be
like meth heads and like like street
people like homeless people living in
his house was crazy
and um you know obviously this is far
worse as his sister you know tried to
take her on live in so sorry but
eventually you just have to you know
it's tough love is a different difficult
thing to say um you kind of have to just
you know like she said live for you you
come first you care of your yeah and
both of you have to see seek therapy
that's the bottom line you need to seek
professional help if both of you are
feeling this blue F day in and day out
you know when not to get even more grim
but when I was 17 I had a massive
suicide attempt I was locked up for a
month my sister was in college she was
depressed she couldn't pick up her own
pieces because her and I were extremely
close and to even think I wrote her a
suicide it was a whole thing I wrote her
a letter everything but because she was
so strong right she was she really was
able to pick me up in her own way and if
it wasn't for the fact that she really
you know hammered down on her own health
and her own stability I don't think I
would have been able to go to her for
support right she wouldn't have been
able to offer as much support as she was
as she was able to do at that time
so get healthy first you can't help
anyone unless you get healthy that's
great that you're back on on better
ground I assume right now better yeah
yeah that's that's when I was 17 I was
just so you know hormonal teenager my
father was dying there were so many
circumstantial things that were
happening in my life yeah so and I I I
had no real guidance at that time I was
left to my own devices and so I just
became a suicidal teenager and
was severely depressed I was in and out
of meds no one told me that I couldn't
just abruptly stop my meds I just didn't
have that guidance sure and so it became
just a recipe for disaster
but thankfully my sister who's almost
two years older than me
she really had it together yeah and it
seems like they have a similar age gap
too so if you think you're that that
person in her life then then focus on
yourself first before you you you reach
out to her well thank God you know he's
getting the answer from you I don't know
if that's the right answer but that's
what you got through it so I'm sure
aren't you unburied [ __ ] or two I fell
for this was very good
reverse hatch very good right now you're
learning
I've had a wash [ __ ] you okay all right
thanks for the clocks and you want money
for the Oasis the great kept an oasis
yeah so you literally fake cried don't
be into a reaction earlier in the show
yeah did you watch the Oasis documentary
loved it Liam Gallagher's comes out this
week I loved it yeah I'm excited for and
that's when I felt guilty watching it
throwing your [ __ ] CDs because I
remember being on the freeway out on
those fine no in fact when we watched a
documentary a couple times he was like
wow I feel really bad thank you yeah
thank you for communicating because I
didn't know much about them because
there was just a big radio I don't like
you know popular music yeah
but then watching the documentary I just
fell in love with them they're talented
guys brothers and whatever yeah and
you'd feel guilty so I apologize if you
ever want the CDs back I don't know I
can buy you a lot of them okay thank you
bye anyway arm